what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here with that cyber channel dance siren
over here yeah you catch them twitch.tv
slash that fiber channel live stream
video game pls oooh youtube.com slash
that cyber channel that's where I've
been promoted in since day one and of
course we part of the PGM squadron dick
youtube.com slash user slash King yeah
that easy to fun we want that down so
I've been saving some of the best game
trailers for that cyber guy over here
because you know III z'n going on I mean
getting up reactions as late as possible
for you guys I just did for you go like
finally yeah that's what all the
comments are good reducing the evil
within two official III announcement
trailer yeah real quick good to be back
good to be back I asked didn't want it
felt real long like five six months yeah
that's what happens when you live like
an hour you play the first one right I
play half the first one I think I
basically rage quit because I was really
tired of something happened that was
shitty to me but like no [ __ ] dude it
happens well guess what
Sebastian's back that's all I know baby
eighteen the he bills
[Music]
screaming OH oh man this guy's can't
break our sim Oh daughter remodeling and
everything and that's creepy
[Music]
wah-wah
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't like people have like weird hand
things I don't like it
[Music]
and now
[Music]
sweet sweet so the nightmares continue
people
the nightmares continues so it looks
like he's on a quest to say I'm assuming
that's his daughter I wasn't I look he
seems like a father right yeah I'm
assuming he's trying to save his
daughter in this version of the game I'm
wondering how much he's changed as a
character his first one he's like fish
out of water yeah it's a fish out of
water like Lauren what's going on
I think it's worried for this game right
now calling back to when I played it the
first time the original one is that I
thought it was gonna be a lot scarier
and it was still kind of like action
shooter he just kind of like I had a gun
so I felt like insanely comfortable all
the way through yeah well I heard that
the gameplay itself like was what you
said yeah and that people expected a lot
more in terms of story wise to obey
expected more yeah I mean by all means
the evil within was not a bad game it's
just the problem with these cinematic
trailers is they make everything look so
cool that'd be good yeah you don't see
gameplay and I don't see like what's
gonna be like is to keep up the visuals
and like yeah the atmosphere like like
this could be so much into it if it was
just a creepy [ __ ] F game right right
right
in terms of story wise I'm thinking what
does the thing called stem and the first
one right the - thing yeah so my pain is
how I explain things videos the mine
things in the first one he's kind of
thrown into this situation and this when
it seems like he's probably good and
intentionally stepping into it yet to
try to save his daughter so kind of
gives it a more personal story as well
especially for a main character yeah I
think so I mean it's better when they're
like the first one of like opens with
like you're in it like you're just like
you're you're in there and that's kind
of men you got to find your way out this
one is very much like I don't want to go
back in but I gotta go then yeah
yeah I'll go back and I'll go back I'm
gonna go back in I don't why I gotta say
like seeing this trailer I'm like I kind
of want to go back out and there's evil
within because this looks this looks
like it's worth it
I'd imagine it step it up a lot because
the first one seemed like it was
received well yet like disappointing
it's kind of like with movies that get a
good score on Rotten Tomatoes but are
still perceived as a disappointment yeah
you know and I feel like that's how the
evil within was kind of perceived at
least from what I would read a lot about
online I know I'm sure this would go out
there get a call box really we talked
about great in it well there's I mean
it's a new IP so like all you have is
like a real solid crown work and all you
can do is build on it and while people
within like it didn't capture me right
away they still have a lot they can
build off with the second one so - what
would you want more out of it to
actually just be scary yeah I like
called evil one reason I want to be on
the edge of my seat and I felt with that
one I felt too comfortable at time for
example there was this one part where
you need to get a keycard and everyone
knows like getting a keycard in a horror
like game or movies you get the key
there's got to be bad and like I
predicted the exact scenario we're gonna
have I go I want less predictability and
I want to come at me hard yeah well I
feel like too with this kind of trailer
because I remember the e3 trailers or
the game fairs for the first evil within
just capitalize on horror elements this
seemed to capitalize on emotional
elements yeah so I'm wondering if they
are going to go down a path of making it
a much bigger because I think this is a
life or death situation with a daughter
um with so I keep saying as daughters if
I know for sure you know is on another
way should it be it's a small girl of it
happening that combining the elements of
or with personal emotion could just make
her overall better and best
of an entire game to be on board with
and can enhance the story aspect if
there's one thing I know that people
were a little let down by was story ask
them yeah I remember why I didn't get
into it it was that there was too much
emphasis on Gore gotcha it was it was
too much about like oh my god you just
went down a meat slide and look at all
this light dancing blutter idea quick
okay yeah what gotcha well you know
people are very excited for this one so
must mean something for something yeah
yeah all right guys well we got a lot
more shutters to watch right now we're
just starting off with this one if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real reject click that
notification bell let you look like a
baby two things okay
here's what's two-step Providence to
like really get it thank you to Dan that
cyber channel on twitch and also on
YouTube you can catch them on the PGM
squadron over at youtube.com Green is
Simon youtube.com slash games it's user
slash games yeah I got an amazing I know
right it's amazing if you like my email
I can't get my wrist Rima 12:30 on ice
cream at 12:30 and on both Thursday and
Friday over there so okay cool come come
get your light